all right well I think I got to like
address some of the haters of the world
here on a Wednesday afternoon or morning
whatever the hell it is all right and
all the people after noon well hey you
know you're always were always talking
hi to you know Sky Sports it's the
afternoon over there I wanted to make it
safe but I think the you know the talk
about oh you know Lamar Jackson's not as
good as we thought he's not the MVP it's
not all that because of what we saw this
past divisional weekend and the loss of
the Tennessee Titans come on erroneous
erroneous on all counts like I just
don't want to hear that first off you
know just because they didn't play their
best game the Baltimore Ravens it
doesn't fall on Lamar Jackson all right
Lamar Jackson had a transcendent year
this year I mean it was unbelievable
it's as his unbelievable year as we've
ever seen from any one player in the
history of football it's right up there
it's every bit as close to what we saw
with Patrick mahomes in the 5,000 yards
and 50 touchdown passes last year I mean
Lamar Jackson was so clearly the MVP and
should have been the unanimous all-pro
so clearly it's not even funny
I don't care what happened last week yes
I get it he threw an interception on the
first drive of the game okay man all
right he still gave them plenty of other
opportunities and I would argue John
Harbaugh listening to his analytics team
going forward on fourth and one those
were the really the big issues of the
game that gave Tennessee Titans all the
confidence and and momentum they want
but to then just look at this and go all
Lamar Jackson see this is why he's not
the MVP or I still have questions about
him you know that that's just false I
that's totally wrong and he did a lot of
good things in this game was he at his
best no certainly not the Ravens got
stuck in a bad position they got stuck
from playing behind they hadn't really
had to do that all year long and it made
them play a game that they're not
accustomed to but it doesn't take away
from the great season we saw from Lamar
Jackson Chris I feel like people were
just kind of lying in wait waiting for
the opportunity to pounce on right 100%
anything bad about him all
regular-season so as a bad postseason
game
oh he's not the MVP he's not the all-pro
quarterback it's
regular-season award and Chris under
that standard yeah they would take away
the MVP trophy of every regular-season
MVP since your guy Kurt Warner in 1999
become one right since then
none of them has won the Super Bowl
twenty years of and in that amazing
twenty years of regular season NFL MVPs
who have not won the Super Bowl
so you could make that same argument for
any of the others and you know what I
don't recall that argument ever coming
up for any other regular-season MVP
you're exactly right in the playoffs
nobody diminished what he did in the
regular season yeah you're right it has
come up with no one and that's the point
and that's where I question all you
haters out there all right I got a quick
one and and this one bugs me and it bugs
me that other people don't realize the
problem here the Falcons have known for
two years that they are going to unveil
new uniforms this spring in April and
they just let people know about it
yesterday
and I really don't care if the folks on
Twitter don't understand my point it's
really not a difficult point it goes
like this people spent good hard-earned
money on expensive Falcons jerseys
throughout the 2019 season now obviously
not as many jerseys as they would have
bought if the team would have been worth
a crap but you get my point
people buy jerseys under the assumption
that they're going to keep wearing that
uniform and at least let people know
when they're making the decision to buy
the $100 cheaper model or the $300
full-blown authentic model that coming
up in April there may be a new model
that you'd like to buy instead and I
just feel like it's some level the
Falcons do exactly what they were doing
here and that bothers me Chris and I
don't care if you disagree with me
either
I feel that way and I'm not changing my
mind more pft live right after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports